when I went to your website for is it
red real video production yeah you you
have in the bio there which is great it
was founded around 2009 and you say
something out of it was born out of the
recession because if you can't get a job
out of college you might as well do
exactly what you want to do yeah even
though we're supposedly in a robust
recovery I know a lot of people are
still feeling the effects of the
recession can you talk about creating
your own job essentially yeah well I
yeah I graduated in 2008 and didn't
really I went to business school because
I was filming since I was a kid
bought my first camera I was 13 but I
don't think it ever really occurred to
me that filmmaking could be a
possibility it was just way too cool for
me he like didn't even it didn't even
occur to me that that was ever going to
happen that didn't even cross my mind so
yeah I ran away from home when I was
about 16 and so there was kind of a pull
yourself up by your bootstraps kind of
big recognition of oh I need to have
stability in my life so when I did go to
college it was for business and focused
on that but went to a liberal arts
school called Fort Lewis College in
Durango Colorado and had amazing
professors that really let me do
whatever I wanted with projects and turn
in videos and it was a great atmosphere
to be in to learn about who I was and
what I wanted to be and after graduating
from there there was just you know not a
lot of jobs it was the the peak of
everyone getting fired from places and
so I decided I would do video production
and that started with you know wedding
videos or tutorials for was really
connected with outdoor industry at that
time so Osprey backpacks and things like
that where they need to do four by three
videos on DP DV tapes and the YouTube
had barely even started so
was just a different time period and
slowly slowly gained confidence enough
to make my first film and it just kind
of took off from there I think you had
made some short films about aspiring
people in the sort of environmental
space yeah I had made a film before that
called 23 feet that was about people
living simply to do what they loved in
the outdoors and took that on a kind of
unorthodox tour where the film was
called 23 feet because I was the size of
my Airstream and created a screen that
came down from the Airstream
and had an outdoor city theater tour
where in 30 different places around the
West showed the film and layout and
outside it was places like you know
Tuolumne meadows that's had Yosemite -
like 30 climbers - a blocked off street
in Portland Oregon with 300 people so it
was an amazing very unique distribution
strategy but I just had no idea about
film festivals or anything like that but
what I did find was people would come up
to me after the screenings or write me
letters later about how they had decided
to you know quit their day jobs and you
know empty their Rentals out and move
into a van and decided to just like you
know live the life that they've always
wanted to live and it was really jolting
to get these letters from people who had
decided to change their life after
seeing a film I had made and really
spoke to how powerful films get me so
after that I'd made move shake which was
a series about people who are dedicating
their lives to their passions of
environmental and social justice and
that was a big learning experience but
made several short films and it was what
led me to making my first feature in
Afghanistan called frame by frame that
was about Afghan photojournalists and so
it's always like getting away from the
outdoor industry and more into topics
that I was interested in around
storytelling do you think if it hadn't
been during the time of the recession
that you would have been less apt to try
that just because you saw so many things
were falling apart that we didn't think
we're gonna fall apart and yeah I think
it's probably not good to say but I
might be the only person who's thankful
for the recession because it was I think
I could have very easily just gotten a
marketing job somewhere if it would have
been a different time but it really
forced me to think okay I could do a job
I really don't want to do and make OK
money or I could do exactly what I want
to do and push myself and that was a
scary scary risk and leap to take but
really glad it turned out that way
obviously